joining us now Pat Ryder Nassau County
Police Commissioner and Randy Sutton
retired police Lieutenant with the Las
Vegas Metropolitan Police Department and
the founder of the Wounded blue okay
commissioner this video is brutal
there's been a conversation about why
release it tonight on a Friday night
there has been a build up we've been
warned about how bad it was and those of
us who have watched it now know
unfortunately that accurate the
description was very accurate it seems
so far tonight that people are
peacefully protesting but what do you
make of the timing of this release and
how it's playing out
well there's a lot that goes on behind
the scenes that the world doesn't get to
see Chief Davis and her team down in
Memphis did a great job they briefed us
three times this week all the law
enforcement agencies around the country
major City Chiefs got a briefing from
the chief and her team giving us the
heads up so we can prepare as she was
also preparing for possible unrest in
our community so the timing of it it's a
difficult choice no you know nobody can
uh pick the right time there's never a
right time to give bad news to anybody
but Chief Davis and the team did a good
job getting it out tonight and as you
can see so far everybody has got staying
calm the messages got out in front and
we'll see how the rest of the weekend
goes
Randy you and I have had this
conversation unfortunately because there
have been other cases like this and we
fear there will be cases like this in
the future but we've talked about my
late father was a law enforcement
officer
um there's nobody who hates a bad cop
worse than a good cop because this now
colors the ability for everybody to get
out there safely and do their jobs when
you've got a community when you've got
people who have been hurt who are wary
of you and don't want to cooperate with
police how much bad has this case done
for the good men and women in uniform
uh you you've hit a a very important
point and you know
um what we have seen here is another
watershed moment I'm afraid in law
enforcement uh Rodney King was a
watershed moment George Floyd and now we
have
um this this debacle in in Memphis as a
police trainer I spent many many years
as a trainer watching what unfolded here
in Memphis was actually shocking to me
um I I saw horrible policing I saw bad
techniques I saw Out of Control Officers
no supervision no leadership and this is
a recipe for what just took place
um there was there was just there was
just it was a Feeding Frenzy and it was
it was policing at its worst now I can
tell you this that that in from my
sources uh in Memphis
um the the rank and file uh realized
that that these individuals when way way
overboard and they support the the
actions of the chief and that that not
doesn't always happen so I'm I'm proud
of of the Memphis officers recognizing
this this misconduct uh but there's a
lot of other issues here uh Shannon that
that we could go into uh reference their
training reference hiring reference uh
you know there's a there's an
investigation needs to take place into
the hiring practices that were taking
place when these none of these cops have
more than two or three years on so you
know if they're if we're all hired about
the same time and you have a it's a
symptom so it really needs to be
addressed and that's something down the
road that the Memphis Police leadership
needs to take a look at
yeah and there are a number of
Investigations state and federal that
will dig into these issues and clearly
make suggestions about what should come
next I want to play what Benjamin Crump
the attorney for the Nichols family said
about race and police culture here's his
take
racism
and bias it is the institutionalized
police culture it's not just the police
culture it's the justice system you
don't see officers doing this to White
Citizens because our court system has
said
that they Value white life more than any
other life
now against that backdrop I thought it
was interesting that the police chief
there in Memphis
um CJ Davis said she thinks this
actually is not an issue of race what
she said is it's about human dignity
integrity and accountability and the
duty to protect our community
um commissioner what do you make of that
part of the conversation
uh they want to make it about race but
the truth of the matter is our job is to
protect and serve all the people no
matter your race religion your gender
we're out there to serve the public
these five offices they threw that out
the window today they decided that they
were going to go above and be better
than the law and what they did in the
attack on on Mr Tyree there is is way
above the training muscle memory
practice how you play everything went
out the window they let their emotions
take over and then they tarnish The
Shield they ruin the reputation of all
the good men and women out there in law
enforcement that work hard every single
day and go out there and take the risk
it's hard enough to retain it's hard
enough to recruit and now it makes it
even more difficult that's why we need
the support of our local politicians
like we do here in Nassau County
back it up yeah for the good folks that
are out there in uniform trying to serve
the community commissioner Randy we
thank you both very much